entre las fronteras interiores de la
unión europea durante la primera ola de
la pandemia de kobe 19 ha provocado que
los países hayan decidido coordinarse un
poco mejor a partir de ahora se aplicará
lo que se conoce como un sistema
semáforo es decir los países en verde
serán los que tienen una baja incidencia
del virus por lo tanto se podrá viajar
libremente entre estos países en werder
sin ningún tipo de restricción luego
estarán en naranja los países que tienen
una incidencia intermedia del virus y
finalmente en rojo los países que tienen
un alto número de casos de covite 19 el
centro europeo de prevención de
enfermedades decidirá según criterios
epidemiológicos como por ejemplo el
número de tres positivos o también el
número de casos por cada 100.000
habitantes para decidir qué países
estarán en cada color eso sí cada país
decidirá qué tipo de medidas y test o
cuarentena aplicará los viajeros
provenientes de zonas rojas de esta
medida coincide con que ahora hay un
aumento cada vez más dramático de casos
en todos los
de la unión europea especialmente en el
centro de europa y además coincide a dos
meses en vista de las vacaciones de
navidad que suele coincidir con un
movimiento muy amplio de pasajeros entre
los aeropuertos la unión europea espera
que ahora los países se puedan coordinar
mejor se pueda dar mejor información a
los viajeros y sobre todo se evite el
cierre de fronteras entre los países de
la unión europea como se vivió en la
pasada primavera